[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux merci d'être en
direct ce matin avec nous pour débattre
du bureau de la sécurité une question
avoue alexandre touzet vous avez
représenté les maires de france en
beauvau de la sécurité vous présentez
votre plan d'urgence pour la sécurité
vous demander notamment une réponse
forte une implication des élus
pensez-vous avoir été entendu lors de
ces concertations
d'écouté ont formulé la semaine dernière
le désigne propositions pour l'instant
jeux de retour
peut-être qu'on aura posé les mots en
discours du trône a rappelé 8 je le
souhaite vivement parce que la
participation de quatre maires de rendre
ces quelques mois a été extrêmement
régulier leur premier tir on espère que
celle de l'état répondra à nos demandes
à la fois une stratégie nationale c'est
avec les élus locaux et puis localement
aussi on puisse va travailler davantage
davantage ensemble et puis répondre à
diverses questions sont ceux des moyens
créatifs qui ferait attribue
aussi l'association des élus la
stratégie nationale et puis la question
des mineurs qui est extrêmement
surprenant puisqu'on voit que il
consistait à la chaire à canon
malheureusement les délinquants
chevronnés leur fugue responsabilités de
l'est met en avant on voit bien que les
12 13 14 ans sont extrêmement utilisé en
fait
par les bobolais pour faire des passes
et des douanes ya des discussions qui
ont quand même duré sept mois
joaquim pueyo vous êtes maire d'alençon
vous avez été vous même confronté aux
violences contre les policiers dans l'un
de vos quartiers vous attendez quoi vous
de la part d' emmanuel macron à roubaix
nous attendons des décisions concrètes
parce que actuellement on en train de
travailler sur un os pratiques sûrs et
est intégré je crois que c'est bien de
travailler avec la police mais se
réserve également que les collectivités
locales à des moyens par exemple pour
alençon à installer 60 caméras quand
même descendre négligeable les dépenses
de fonctionnement 1 million 3 n'a été
dessertes mais ce n'est pas suffisant et
nous nous sommes tout à fait partant de
travailler dans un esprit constructif
avec l'état et avec la police nationale
en renforçant les effectifs de la police
municipale se réserve également que la
police nationale se renforce en termes
d'effectifs et de travailler d'une
manière constructive par exemple dans
l'orne avec monsieur le procureur de la
république on a mis en place un groupe
de prévention contre la délinquance qui
fonctionne bien autour d'une table
javaux la police n'avons les services de
la collectivité les services sociaux les
services de l'éducation nationale pour
traiter de manière très précise les
jeunes délinquants puisque mon collègue
effectivement il ya un travail des
mineurs stella n'a des mineurs qui sont
et qui ont rompu la chaîne républicaine
il faut les intégrer à ses demandes eu
un travail fin de concertation avec tous
les acteurs ou qui sont sur un
territoire qui ont été ouverts lors de
ces discussions du bureau de la sécurité
la réponse pénale l'encadrement la
formation au contrôle mal le maintien de
l'ordre ou le lien police-population
voyez ce qu'en pensent les premiers
concernés on en parle après
certaines tables rondes ont libéré la
parole en tout cas nous on ne s'est pas
privé pour la prendre on a suffisamment
réfléchi maintenant il est temps de
passer à l'action avec des décisions
ambitieuses et courageuses si ça fait
pschitt et qu'on se retrouve seulement
avec une déclaration d'amour du
président on se demandera à quoi tout ça
aura servi il faudrait une refonte
totale ce n'est pas un beauvau qu'il
faut c'est une réforme complète de toute
l'institution police il ya une frange de
population contre laquelle il ne faut
pas avoir peur de dire qu'il faut
déclarer une guerre ce qu'ils sont
capables d'aller dans les quartiers est
de sortir en pleine rue avec des ak 47
des kalachnikovs qui vous tire quand
même des dragées de 7,62 il faut arrêter
c'est une arme de guerre avec des
munitions de guerre alors vous voyez les
policiers salut il y adeux l'écoutant
mais à entendre celui de marseille il
faudrait vraiment déclaré la guerre à
ces gangs armés avoir le courage
politique de le faire est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça joaquim pueyo
malheureusement quelques images
fictivement qui exprime bien la colère
des policiers je pense que c'est un
sujet qui ne concerne pas uniquement la
petite nation je pense qu'il ya un
problème également sur la chaîne pénale
vous doit renforcer les peines parce que
nous voyons ce genre de violences d'
attaque qu'au cateau liste je pense
qu'il faut réformer la loi pénale à ce
sujet il a ensuite très convaincu si on
veut redonner également du courage et
d'espoir parce que actuellement les
policiers sont en difficulté pour le
reconnaître qu on voyait qu'ils sont en
permanence insulter agresser dans
certains secteurs dans un secteur est
bien évident que c'est pas ça donc je
pense que
c'est important le renforcement de
l'effet aussi l'information des boîtiers
et doit être déterminant également le
travail avec les collectivités locales
les indispensables parce que nous
connaissons bien le terrain nous
connaissons également nos populations
mais il faut aller plus loin il faut
revoir équipements l'échelle des peines
par rapport à certains comportements par
rapport à certaines crime lorsque l'on
atteint même très frontal des policiers
ou des gendarmes
alexandre une réaction à cette
déclaration de guerre demandé par ce
policier à marseille concrètement la
réponse pénale vient après mais sur le
terrain au lieu de de rebrousser chemin
est ce qu'il faut apporter une réponse
plus plus musclé selon vous
je peux pas laisser dire que les
policiers ou les gendarmes
occupe le terrain dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
parfois ce sont des incursions très
rapide parce qu'ils savent que des
représailles immédiates mais
heureusement ils vont encore partout
c'est vrai qu'il reste pas très
longtemps sont des interventions
extrêmement difficile c'est pour ça
qu'on a notamment parlé dans le cas de
ce nouveau des conditions matérielles
c'est encore des progrès à faire sur les
équipements on avait notamment ceux
détenus qui prenait l'eau on voit bien
qu'il ya des problèmes
d'équipement
est décrite ici sur place donc c'est un
sacré sens de bord où je partage aussi
quitté et je sais un regret qu'on n'est
pas cheminer de façon conjointe sur la
police et la justice je pense qu'il nous
faut nous à programmation police justice
qui qui chemine parallèlement parce que
on voit bien que la justice est
complètement embouteillée aujourd'hui
face à la masse des affaires il faut
aussi des formations communes police
magistrats il faut davantage de travail
en commun il faut sortir un peu de ce
face à face au but connaître depuis de
trop nombreuses années et puis ce
partage avec mon collègue l'idée qu'il
faut avoir un traitement de tous ces
actes de défiance envers celles et ceux
qui incarnent l'autorité et les
policiers les gendarmes les enseignants
tout le personnel de santé il faut que
ça constitue véritablement priorité
comité qu'on enseigne à l'école dès le
plus jeune âge le fait de s'arrêter
quand un policier dit quelque chose et
leur novelli quand ils mentent arrête
invitons l'art est le véhicule il faut
que ça fasse partie notamment
l'enseignement et qu'on en tire des
conséquences judiciaires vu tous les
dangers qui s'impose comment on fait
pour établir cette ce respect selon vous
écoutez moi je pense que trop souvent
entre la parole d'un délinquant et la
parole d'un policier ou d'un
la gendarme une sorte de neutralité qui
est parfois mise en avant par la justice
je pense que la parole d'un policier la
parole d'un gendarme doit être davantage
écouter une que j'ai pu rencontrer de
nombreux policiers des gendarmes dans le
cadre de ce beau et mon activité est
très souvent quand niveau entre les
pénale ils voient bien leur parole est
remise en cause et a suffisamment
entendue par l'autorité judiciaire si on
veut traiter tous ces actes de défiance
il faut dès le départ mais je pense et
des outrages l'outragé quelque chose de
grave et on voit bien que ces traités et
c'est insuffisamment traitées par la
justice il faut poser des interdits et
les interdits ça veut dire qu'à un
moment il ya un aspect éducatif à
l'école dans les 18 propositions des
mères vous verrez qu'il y a tout un
cheminement du site et jusqu'à la
terminale où on renoue ce lien avec la
police la gendarmerie la justice l'armée
les personnels de secours il ya tout un
aspect éducatif de prévention il ya
aussi un espèce de sanction et sa des
premiers dérapages des outrages il faut
pas laisser passer ces faits là on voit
bien souvent qu'on organise en fait un
parcours
malheureusement délinquants en ne
sanctionnant pas suffisamment en avant
en amont il pas suffisamment précocement
dans un parcours délinquant on autorise
malheureusement ou qu'on incite en
manquant quand il s'agit d'un figé des
sanctions joie qui me payant vous
parliez des magistrats de la justice les
magistrats se sont assez critiques sur
le bobo de la sécurité puisque eux mêmes
dénoncent l'absence justement de
représentants syndicaux des personnels
de justice il
des magistrats je vous le rappelle qui
avait été accusé de laxisme par les
policiers écouter
on ne souhaitait évidemment pas assisté
à toutes les tables rondes mais on a
trouvé dommage qu'aucun représentant des
personnels de justice ne puisse répondre
aux attaques de certains policiers il
aurait fallu les entendre son nom vous
joaquim pueyo dans ce beauvau de la
sécurité bien sûr c'est indispensable je
pense que que le move et d'insécurité
c'est quand même lié à la justice
également donc je crois qu'il aurait
fallu peut-être également que les
organisations professionnelles des
magistrats puissent participer parce que
en fait sur terrain notamment de l'ebit
de moyenne on voit très bien que le
travail qui se fait entre la police
nationale je vois alençon et le parquet
ce fonds se fait dans des bonnes
conditions et un travail concret
souterrain et donc je crois que c'est
indispensable à mon avis qu'au niveau
national les magistrats soient associés
à ce travail parce que ça permettrait et
qui - de réfléchir sur les réponses
pénales sur les sanctions ça peut
également déboucher sur un travail
commun sur la prévention tu d'accord
avec mon collègue la prévention
indispensable à sanction également et je
suis allé au danemark lorsque j'étais
parlementaire dans le cadre d'une
mission parlementaire mais on s'est
rendu compte que dans ce pays par
exemple les magistrats la police les
acteurs sociaux travaillent main dans la
main d'une manière permanente avec des
commissions pluridisciplinaires et c'est
comme ça qu'on fait avancer
effectivement je crois à l'état de droit
qui quelquefois peut être faux mise en
question dans certains endroits donc il
faut qu'on en force est un droit il faut
qu'on renforce les valeurs apple dit
qu'elle le respect de l'autorité je
crois que ça passe effectivement par
d'éducation de la formation mais
également il faut le dire par des
sanctions lorsque des policiers se font
attaquer voir des pompiers voire de ce
qui représente le traité public peut
plus fonctionner comme ça il faut
absolument stopper et mettre en place
des nouvelles procédures je crois
beaucoup au travail pluridisciplinaire
et donc faso sied bien évidemment les
magistrats d'ailleurs on constate qu'il
ya eu des efforts de fait récemment pour
renforcer le nombre de magistrats les
moyens de la justice n'est pas encore
suffisant il faut aller un peu plus loin
parce que les tribunaux sont cons
quelques pas encombrer les magistrats du
mal à suivre leur dossier parce qu'ils
sont sont pas assez nombreux donc au lit
oui justice également c'est très lié à
mon avis alexandre touzet autres
critiques elles elles viennent des
associations antiracistes qui déplore un
entre soi et un corporatisme de cette
concertation regarder
la question du racisme a été totalement
évacué du beauvau j'avais
personnellement demandé à être reçus
lors de la table ronde dédiée à la
relation police population mais cela m'a
été refusé sur ce thème il n'y a pas eu
de dialogue avec la société civile selon
vo fallait-il aussi associer ces
associations au débat
c'était le rôle aussi des élus des élus
locaux des élus des parlementaires de
prendre contact que ce que nous avons
fait moi j'ai pris des contacts avec les
associations de jeunes vous êtes des
belles sur toute une soirée avec eux
j'étais pas forcément d'accord pour eux
mais c'était le boulot des vues locaux
il je crois qu'on a fait on l'a
retranscrit dans nos 18 propositions
lorsqu'il fallait élargir on était pas
l'organisateur mais je pense que ce
travail a été créé par les élus locaux
après je
rentrerai pas dans les débats
il ya parfois des actes racistes ça peut
arriver maintenant jaurès minier
néanmoins que la police et la
gendarmerie sont très diverses
qu'il représente
notamment au balai chez les gardiens
mais la diversité du pays s'il faut dire
c'est pas une police blanche raciste
c'est des termes que je ne peux pas
reprendre il ya quelques années ils sont
sanctionnés arrêtons avec ces débats
antirépublicain
au projet l'image d'une police assists
c'est complètement faux je pense qu'on
fait du mal à la république et comme et
pas les jeunes fassent aussi à leurs
responsabilités voilà moi je suis pour
qu'on sanctionne quo quand il ya des
travers moyen des erreurs on les
sanctionne est d'ailleurs la police et
le corps de fonctionnaires ne plus
contrôler le plus sanctionné en france
il faut rétablir cette vérité mais ne
confondons pas quelques dérapages amis
et la police dans sa globalité qui
représentent la diversité du pays et qui
est une police essentiellement un public
aime parler de sanction le chef de
l'état devrait annoncer un contrôle
indépendant des forces de l'ordre cet
après midi à roubaix est ce que ce
serait la fin 2-2 les gpm souvent accusé
de parti pris avec la police joaquim
pueyo votre votre réaction
pourquoi pas le contrôle plus
indépendant us et à mon avis on l'a vu
dans certaines instances par exemple les
prisons sont contrôlés également devenir
indépendant l'aîné section générale qui
est indispensable qu'il y ait un
contrôle indépendant je crois que c'est
bien ça permet effectivement de
renforcer à la fois la transparence mais
moi je voudrais pas non plus qu'il y ait
systématiquement de la suspicion à
l'égard des policiers eux ils font un
travail difficile les policiers font un
travail très compliqué ce territoire et
la population
apprécie le travail des gendarmes et
état et étaient de la police alors
effectivement quelques fois il n'y a ni
pas voir des des difficultés avec partie
certains jeunes moi je sais qu'en tant
que maire d'une ville et président de la
communauté urbaine ou rend compte déjà
la police qui rencontre également et ça
se passe souvent dans des bonnes
conditions parce que beaucoup de jeunes
comprennent effective entre la loi on
doit la respecter que le respect c'est
important que la dignité c'est important
nous croiser ya un travail d'information
et de formation mais faisons attention à
des propos par rapport à 6 mon dieu en
disant que la police peut avoir des
gestes
déplacés ça arrive quelques fois mais il
ya du contrôle et jeudi également que
pour avoir suivi ni effectivement des
équipes de police l'art conditions de
travail extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement compliqué donc c'est un
travail de fond qui doit aborder la
formation va jouer un rôle important et
mon collègue l'a dit à juste titre les
policiers sont contrôlés comme tous les
fonctionnaires d'ailleurs il ya des
contrôles qui se font régulièrement si
on peut les rendent un peu plus
indépendant pourquoi pas à moi je suis
pas contre la dépendance d'un contrôle
mais vous verrez que ça peut être
bénéfique pour tout le monde
elles ont toutes et votre réaction à se
se contrôle indépendant qui va être
annoncé par emmanuel tron
croyez-vous pas confondre deux choses il
ya à la fois si vous voulez le contrôle
individuel quand il ya des problèmes qui
la relève du disciplinaire relève
éventuellement du pénal et dans ce cas
là je pense que ça va être des
professionnels puisque ça implique
secret de l'instruction ça avec des
actes d'instruction qui correspond
parfois un code de procédure pénale ou à
des codes à terme d'aegon administratif
interne et puis à le contrôle de
l'activité qui l'activité globale de le
des forces de sécurité à l'intérieur et
là on pourrait imaginer qui est une
instance un peu comme en belgique qui
réunissent associations élus locaux et
mina sionneau et qu'ils discutent des
évolutions nécessaires pour poursuivre
cette réflexion sur qu'on a eu dans le
cas des bobos la sécurité pour réfléchir
à quel point est le maintien de l'ordre
demain quelles pourraient être les
formes de relations avec la population
quelle stratégie on devrait mettre en
oeuvre je pense qu'il faut distinguer
après la 1re épreuve lui parle du
plaisir d'un public si c'est créer une
instance parlementaire je pense que
c'est un peu étroits existent déjà la
commission des lois qui peut tout à fait
remplir ce rôle
serait davantage sur une instance qui
soient davantage ouverte à la société
civile on a il nous reste quelques
minutes faudrait d'autres réactions à
cette affaire de deux bouteilles de jus
de fruits est vendu chez monoprix qui
comporte des insultes contre les
policiers qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en avez vous entendu parler d'ailleurs
joakim peyo et est votre réaction suite
alexandre touzet non je n'ai pas entendu
parler mais si c'est une sas et de l'ama
inacceptable c'est le chargement c'est
inacceptable j'espère que la justice
sera saisie de cette manière là c'est
une marque allemande et monoprix a
vouvoyé retirer aussitôt évidemment ces
bouteilles de ses rayons votre réaction
alexandre retou z je suis extrêmement
qu'à l'heure parce que ça peut paraître
anodin moi je viens d'un département
calvi qui s'appelle viol et châtiment
will et puis si qui ont il ya quelques
années brûlé et encore quelques jours à
corbeil essonnes des polices ils ont été
sauvagement attaqué je suis vraiment en
colère contre cette forme de
communication que ce soit
fête de l'huma
aujourd'hui cette bouteille de jus de
fruits parce que il ya des femmes et des
hommes il ya des familles derrière les
policiers derrière les gendarmes et jeux
qui exercent un mail ci parce que l'on
périlleux il faut savoir que ces
policiers ce que ces policiers a dit
très souvent très loin de leur lieu
d'exercice parce qu'ils ont peur pour
leur famille ils ont peur pour leurs
enfants je pense qu'il faut arrêter ces
jeux totalement idiot de mettre en
danger
par une sorte de rumeurs ces discours
ambiant
vraiment je suis très en colère parce
que derrière il ya des femmes et des
hommes qu'on met en danger merci
beaucoup joaquim pueyo et merci à vous
alexandre touzet d'avoir participé ce
matin en direct au débat sur rt france